last week played a tournament on
chess.com opened with basically the the
worst possible move on the board and his
opponent a player from Azerbaijan just
resigned because he was so offended yeah
Ralph mamadov very strong azerbaijani
Grandmaster he just gave up after one
move he said okay he doesn't want to
play chess like this
it's a very emotional reaction it's kind
of understandable if someone did that
against me I would be like come on take
it seriously but
I mean it's not necessarily a handicap I
mean he's actually helping Mama Dove if
anything if Magnus is going to play a
bad move let him that gives you a
helping hand to beat Magnus maybe and
we've seen Magnus do it before so it's
nothing personal even against John
Christoph doodle right yeah Magnus it's
as if he's rolling a dice or something
sometimes he's just randomly choosing
moves and uh it's a psychological Ploy I
mean it's not breaking the laws of Chess
it's a valid move and if the opponent
gets flustered that's on them yeah so um
yeah that in uh in those games Magnus
was opening every white game with one g